foreign
[Music]
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky my dad
this was built on their shoulders
can I help you let me get all the grass
no I ain't sounding an autographs but
you get off my car you all remember me
huh
foreign
[Music]
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
she's got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
girls what happened with you too oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
you don't always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in a cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Amy was like family
[Music]
oh we passed talking then maybe you just
have to find out
family times I recognize mine I know
that they needed me
manifest got my only fear I ain't scared
of death did you hear me yet
I need you to lick all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah
you know
foreign
[Music]
don't you dare let that little red dog
piss on my walkway again ignore him
Prince he has no idea who's doing that
well it was one of you
[Music]
cannot use this road without a permit
have a nice day sir you know the other
guys don't do this the guys with the
white trucks how come it's always you
brown guys and I don't mean that
racially
I'm sorry to get me earlier the whole
neighborhood has fallen apart these days
[Music]
oh my God give me the keys
hello hello what's your name Otto
Otto o-t-t-o I'm Abby o-t-t-o
got some new neighbors my Edward husband
I brought you some food okay okay bye
are you always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're not every word
you say is like a warm cuddle
[Music]
can you please give me a ride I don't
have a license you don't have a driver's
license how old are you
[Music]
a hybrid
how did you get in here
no no no you are not taking over my bed
I was wondering if you could help us out
I'm not sure about this it's gonna be
very fun
how was it you did a good job you should
pat yourself on the back
[Music]
[Music]
to do everything on your own guess what
no one came
[Music]
it was all the Clown's fault
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we hold the king of the Coopers
foreign
that is but a taste of our Fury
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
huh
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die oh
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
family
and baby Glade what is the president
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition I'm not my
father he was the Explorer I know you
were just a kid when you went missing
but now you're all we got Mr clade I'm a
huge fan thank you of your dad
where in the world are we Ethan you
brought the dog he just wants to help
yeah
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
uh hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones uh is this thing dangerous
[Music]
it's so cute I want to merchandise it
[Music]
I'll be inside
come on we got a world to save let's get
moving
[Music]
just for nightmare tunnel just be brave
[Music]
family
that's what I'm talking about okay
Albert no around them yeah
foreign
[Music]
this is our chance
to control the truth the concepts of
right and wrong for everyone for
centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you lost your parents welcome home
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plants
I have this project at work do you want
to see yes
foreign
ever since I was little I dreamed of
this perfect toy that would protect a
kid from ever feeling lonely or sad this
is Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
your goal is to protect Katie from harm
both physical and emotional is that a
doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for short I can't believe you made this
I love it
great job it's nice to have a friend
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetable they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes I can turn off
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk Make Her Say Something
stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
Megan she pushed Brandon onto the road I
won't let anything harm you
thank you
turn off recalibrating response model
[Music]
what's wrong with you don't worry Kitty
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
surface world
thank God we know what you whisper
show them
Who We Are
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what is all of this I am your Ghost of
Christmas present Like A Christmas Carol
we
[Music]
think I'm gonna be all intrigued by
what's behind the door not even a little
bit curious
damn it
[Music]
my first save it was this little sick
kid
what did they call him it was Tiny Tim
no no sweet kid one crutch little Larry
no Tiny Tim micro Mike super small Steve
Holy
foreign
people settle in relax
give me a call
this is on the line
are you ready I'm always ready we're
expecting your calls talk to Elvis live
on air and tell him about all of your
issues and problems
if it isn't the greatest radio host
[Music]
okay we got Gary on the line what to say
you Gary
foreign
belong to someone you know no it belongs
to somebody not very nice and I'm gonna
take out his whole family
[Music]
Gary what was that I'm breaking into the
top hey Gary stop wait come on why I
hurt his family I mean they're innocent
you're better than that Gary tell me
calmly
where exactly are you
your house
I wait
of your life see I created a game and I
think you're gonna love it
[Music]
this can still end well
I wanted to end well
I don't want to die here
[Music]
and if we don't want to die we gotta
fight
[Music]
how about you tell us the truth we're
all listening show yourself your
slimmery Sonoma
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down
what innocent people start getting hurt
it's been asleep for 5 000 years
you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the breath who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
the Justice Society
I got them we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
you didn't come here to seek Justice
you came to exact Revenge
[Music]
I never said I was a hero
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
foreign
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go I always wanted
to be part of something bigger
I love that answer something that lasts
that means something something more
important than life yeah
[Music]
it's written in the stars I am a star
so I have money I would only spend it on
things that were fun you know not boring
things like taxes I'm just wanting for
everyone to party forever
[Applause]
when I first moved to LA Times when all
the doors said no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that
and now y'all ready for something
different
thank you
you know we have to do we have to
redefine the form map those dreams and
print them into history look up and say
Eureka I'm not alone
all right
foreign
[Applause]
let's hang up who wants to see me fight
a snake
hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
know one thing
wherever we go
this family
I
[Music]
is our Fortress
[Music]
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left it in the
bathroom
looks like he's leading a porn Safari
oops you forgot to put his shirt all the
way
up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boot is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice
won't work why so many steps
not once that I wonder
if I'd be walking Hancock
Through the Jungle with a life grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
I wanted something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
freaking love this game
come on get your lazy ass up all right
all right above already that's what you
get staying out partying all night I'm a
promoter I'm working I got like 18 000
followers you know who got followers
Jesus take your rude ass to work you
just cursed what would Jesus say Jesus
will say shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
accounts just bluffed itself crib is
this man Steve Jobs Steve Jobs is dead
fool I mean his house died
you got Miami [ __ ] Cleveland [ __ ] La
[ __ ] damn bigger city bro
oh my God we in LeBron's house LeBron
who James hey there oh you are one
handsome [ __ ] he got a hologram
of himself just to give him compliments
you handled the decision to go to Miami
perfectly nah that's cap
I need 10 G's by next week I gotta pay
for my daughter's school they on
vacation how about we throw the party in
the King's house we gonna invite all the
celebrities we can make 10 times the
money we can send Destiny to preschool
College whatever tonight is our last
shot looks like we help out there
Hi I see you there how are you oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm going to jail hi I'm Peter
is LeBron home
um by the way
black lives matter they do I posted two
squares on my Instagram respect
[Applause]
[Music]
I wouldn't do something like this unless
I was desperate
she cracking bro
[Music]
this party is
[ __ ] we've done [ __ ] up the koala
you good what the [ __ ] just happened
your hairline is perfect anyone who says
otherwise it's just jealous this guy
[Music]
I heard it myself
[Music]
foreign
slaves are free
[Music]
Lincoln
[Music]
's Army five days through this one
[Music]
die
there are many ways to die here
[Music]
I will not be afraid I can immune man do
to me
follow the south of Lincoln's cannons
my family is with me forever
[Music]
I will look in Triumph
at my enemies
some folks say What Goes Down In the
Heat of passion can hard about it
forever
that's life in Mississippi in a way
I have to ask some questions
does your daddy have any
enemies well well maybe I was the target
what do you mean I lost a lot of money
when the merger didn't go through people
lost thousands and thousands of dollars
[Music]
hello where will you please may you wake
up
I got a call today sort of threatening
threatening phone calls this guy may not
be done
whenever there's a murder we ask who
stands the game from it hello who is
this
what can you tell me about the lane
she's been doing a lot of extra shifts
she liked to gamble
when do I get my money I'm broke too why
I think I'm doing all this
an insurance company wanted it's on line
one
problem
you're being used the land stands to get
500
000 balance
to a perfect plan
and getting rich
played right into their hands
[Music]
[Music]
I've been an Olympic and crying
we're trying to control it
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right I know you don't
we also need courage
[Music]
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
if you want
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
oh whatever happens
we'll be ready
exactly that you bring to this I'm a
planner I make plans you've already made
the plants so the existing plan fails I
make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
[Music]
it must be Italian
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
ho ho
you ain't driving are you I steer a
little but the reindeer do my sword
this is my full fear of the center how
about you
I started the whole damn thing
[Music]
we decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline
Santa Claus himself I can talk to Santa
all right revelers welcome back to your
worst Christmas shopping let's go
you have 300 million dollars in your
personal vault
for Christmas
[Music]
laughs
I don't want any trouble okay someone's
gonna scooch up that chimney
who is he because he's not your typical
Mall Santa
are you there
you were very busy tonight
[Music]
time for some Seasons beatings
who the hell are you
but what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
he's Batman
they're all my naughty lick naughty
that's naughty and what do you do to the
naughty ones I give my love for cold
where is this I gotta watch
but I believe in you Santa
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
but you can't spend the night not all
night
so where'd you move here from anyway
Eastern Shore
try that
[Music]
you didn't
the cops get here you have to be good
and gone I can't help you anymore I know
it's not your fault you were born this
way you ate them I believed you had to I
don't know why
it's about you I didn't know I could do
that
I thought I was the only one
I don't want to hurt anybody famous last
words
[Music]
are there lots of us
why are you happy to bring me along you
seem nice I am nice
okay I'm looking for you I smelled you
can smell me half a mile away
can you do that not that far I got rules
never never ever eat an eater
thought you might be hungry for hands no
he lives here is there someone dead out
there
[Music]
I'm not gonna be like that we don't have
many options either you eat you off
yourself or you lock yourself up in
there we're dangerous
one of us
chicks teach me how to smell other
eaters but we can cut one another
Justice are bad
go go
too much
you gotta do this we have to do it
you've been following me and we got
unfinished business
you know I'm thinking of a bad person
[Music]
did my daughter Eloise come she left a
note for you you can just read it
ourselves here Mom I need some pool it's
all I've ever wanted was to feel like a
part of this family I thought maybe my
wedding would be a chance to reconnect
eating
I see now that maybe we were never
really connected
it's real shame on it
[Music]
oh my God have you seen this invitation
are you going to the wedding Eloise is
our half sister which means weekend half
has the relationship
my rich sister chose to stay in London
and shove fish and chips up her butt
that's not how you eat them
this is nice the company upgraded me
very cool country mouse I figured that
everyone in business class was going to
be hot and mean like you they got
Paddington on this flight
stink
[Music]
my sister's the worst thank you for
coming to England my nuptials she's like
netaporte and I'm like Nordstrom Rack
Alice the wine is spelling you bet it is
Mom she sounds like a monster so lovely
having you all here only 72 hours until
the big eye too oh my God Alice I'm fine
I think I just add some bad chicken I
have any chicken
it's wonderful being here with my
children and all their friends you know
he's not my friend you know I support
you Excuse me yes sir yes he's my son
what's happening and they do sex things
it's a-okay with me and I'm proud
From This Moment forward you will behave
like a normal family who is here to
happily celebrate a loved one's wedding
is that understood she's even prettier
when she's angry absolutely radiant
[Music]
but every wedding there are those people
everyone talk about after cousin Randy
oh who are those people this time oh
Savage Mom
[Applause]
[Music]
let's begin
[Music]
you're gonna end this
foreign
you will never have my permission where
is she no come on
you need to help my daughter
load up let's get to it
do you think anyone's following us
we're okay is it smart golden sure I'll
make it right in the end
my men and I are here to bring that boy
in alive so if you're here in some sort
of Vendetta slightly complicated things
Mary I will find him and you're welcome
to every piece of him when I'm done
hear me
I was in control here
your horses carry this sent to death as
you wander around this desert like a
bunch of children
a lot of men enforcing your loss on
foreign land I am tired of it
[Music]
is not the way
peace doesn't follow death
[Music]
hey you good
and look if it get dark now you just
ride it okay yeah yeah how do I do that
[Music]
all right what's done
being back here you all got love for
this city
[Music]
I love the city you know what it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wish I could be
heart of that world
[Music]
have you given any thought to where this
ends
the table will never stop
do you know this
no one
not even you
kill everyone
you ready John
foreign
[Music]
States stands for an idea whose time is
now Ronald Reagan will win tonight what
a schmuck
I think I want to be an artist when I
grow up gonna be an artist if you want
to be nothing's going to stop you you're
going to college go have dinner with
Kings if he plays his cards right
I really like your stickers my step
brother gave them to me he's in the Air
Force that's so cool
how dare you oh menace to you
well you're not to associate with him
again what do you mean why I think you
know what I mean
my parents are sending me to my
brother's school it's heavy
in this institution you can be anything
you want to be it won't be because of a
handout it'll be because you earned your
way there
someone's bugging you what is it
sometimes kids say bad words about the
black kids who's there somebody from my
old school
did they ever come to your house what'd
you do when that happens obviously
nothing of course
[Music]
you come here
the soldiers and sometimes they go out
looking for Jews
they hated us then they still hate us
thank you
so I got on the boat and we came over
here to America the land of dreams
[Music]
you just wanted to be like you I want
you to be a whole lot better than me
life is unfair be thankful when you get
a leg up you make the most of your break
and do not look back all my hopes are
with you and your brother in my whole
life
thank you
no Schmucks or anything bad about those
kids and you're gonna say something
that'd be a match okay firm handshake
okay give me a hug
don't sit down
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's me
[Music]
I thought you would have she ate the
best sushi in L.A wondering
is all game
and if you make it through the night
then I'm gonna let you live
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just need to lay low tonight
how are you surviving now huh
no one beats him he's like a monster
I'm not gonna go anywhere sweetheart
what are you
[Music]
because
[Music]
how you doing Mom oh I'm good now that
you've graced me with your presence
hey I know this is going to sound random
but
you gonna have tests coming from Every
Which Way and I need you to pay
attention to the people you surround
yourself with
think before you react
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why are we here
you thought giving your life to him
would keep me from you
you can't just show up here with no
warning what's wrong does something
happen
yes
Nicholas has come to live with me and
he's improving but he's a little fragile
so why you came to see me you're blaming
me for what happened
he's different from the others what
makes you say that why don't you answer
me I do answer you the look in his eye
is disturbing she wants to turn us
against one another
there's so much joy in our family I feel
like a complete failure if I'm like this
it's your fault what have I done what's
my fault haven't I always done
everything for you I have the right to
reinvent my life it is my life
[Music]
everything okay at home yeah
everything's fine
quite as long
the absence of love the end of love the
Need For Love
result in so much violence
[Music]
it was all waiting to happen before it
happened
you could look back and follow the
breadcrumbs along the path that led to
violence
when we looked back it had been
everywhere
it is a part of our faith to forgive we
will be forced to leave the colonies if
we do not forgive these men
none of you will listen to reason we
know that we've not imagined these
attacks
we know that we are rude and terrified
the unknown is good
[Music]
and we cannot endure any more violence
[Music]
we have been preyed upon like animals
maybe we should respond like animals
how would you feel within your entire
life
[Music]
never mattered what you thought
and we've liberated ourselves
we will have to ask ourselves Who We Are
[Music]
okay time to go you you can't leave me
and Rodrick alone together for a whole
weekend don't forget to unload the
dishwasher
I can teach you lots of things little
brothers I call it my rod Rick rolls
don't you mean roderick's rules Roderick
rule number one no apostrophes or any
other nerd stuff
[Applause]
it's party time
so what's rule number two you only get
one roll a week that's logic rule number
two that's not fair rule number three
life's not fair and now you made me
break rule number two uh
roderick's been taking me under his wing
been teaching me a bunch of stuff what
kind of stuff
I've got potential
[Music]
attention
mean you're gonna have our battles
but when the chips are down don't let
him get away I'm gonna have your back
and you better have mine
Audrey what you look like you wet
yourself
[Music]
it's nasty
girl number 10 always go out in a blaze
of glory Susan
oh see I can't unsee that
[Music]
spot priest s okay
yeah
foreign
police station would you be able to come
to the Institute we think she might be
Chinese some come to get a job and send
money to their families in China life is
tough for them and they're all alone the
organ removal was done right by a
surgeon organ trafficking
do you have a child no yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hi do you have a booking with us yes
first room on the right
hello
Idris did anyone come
excuse me
I can't believe it
my ex-wife is upstairs Patricia this is
Luis uh seems like she's been a good
influence you're not drinking we're
having a great time but now I'm gonna
feel really bad when I get you to start
drinking
I'm aware of how uncomfortable the
situation is I love you right yeah
what are you doing
you're impossible
I need time to uh catch up I guess lover
boy why do you have that love to do
music
[Music]
we're here now aren't we it's really
something
I always wants to have a baby what'd you
just say
oh you got me riding a baby maker
these old miserable bastards you were
just having a bit of fun I love you
[Music]
why didn't you tell me your dad died you
coward you can't deal with anything
it's been quite a lot of them screaming
it's a nightmare situation for everyone
involved
away
away
are you still writing songs about me
I'll never forget
it
again
keep working
[Music]
[Music]